foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
turmoil and tear gas in France as
protesters and police Clash on May Day
with nearly 300 arrested and over a
hundred police officers injured
here the nurses warning they could keep
striking until Christmas but a paid deal
for NHS workers tomorrow is now
described as a foregone conclusion
as the exits from Sudan closed with more
than 2 000 people evacuated by the UK
government we hear the anguish of those
on their way out
I'm thankful for the opportunity to go
back home but
I'm not number 48 I'm Mishka doctor
it's great to be home says Donald Trump
as the former U.S president flies in to
open another golf course in Scotland
coronations then and now we speak to
some of those lucky enough to have been
part of Queen Elizabeth's crowning
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
front pages that's coming up in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening May Day is a
traditional date for people to take to
the streets of Paris but today saw
hundreds of thousands out across the
country as demonstrations were
turbocharged by the protest against
President mackerel's pension reforms
there were violent clashes between
protesters and police in the capital
leading to 108 police officers being
injured including at least one seriously
hurt by a Molotov cocktail 291 people
have been arrested Nationwide while
Europe crossed one at Annan Parsons
joins us live now from Paris Adam
yeah it is amazing how quickly this city
gets back to normal after a day like
this but this was a tumultuous Affair
about violence and conflict around Paris
and indeed on the very street corner
where I'm standing now and it was built
on various ingredients and May Day
protest another National strike a
demonstration here attended by over a
hundred and ten thousand people a small
minority of those who had come to incite
violence a third element the police who
said that they would be harsh against
anybody who tried to disrupt this
demonstration and finally a lingering
sense of anger and grievance among the
French people at the pension reforms
brought in by their president Emmanuel
macron put those together and what Paris
and France ended up with was a volatile
cocktail that ended in Fury and violence
[Music]
Paris reverberated to the sights sounds
and smells of conflict
more than a hundred thousand people took
to the streets in this city
the annual demonstration to Mark workers
rights this year peppered with political
Fury about pension reforms
this was the 13th in a long line of
protests
there were constant battles with the
riot police who snatched targets out of
the crowd
and used tegas relentlessly
and in return they were attacked
constantly here an injured officer
carried to safety one of more than a
hundred hurt across the country
in Lyon cars set on fire there were
running battles in other cities
the protest was everywhere enveloping
the country
and the focus of all this anger was the
president Emmanuel macron
is overridden Parliament to push through
his reform program posed by the great
majority of his nation in One Direction
yes but is he still legitimate and the
art is this reforms legitimate I don't
think so no there's different ways for
people to express their opinion and the
street is one of them
the violence was mainly instigated by
the so-called Black Block groups here
simply to incite conflict
here smoke billowing from fires started
deliberately at Place de la nacion one
of the city's main gateways well these
Mayday protests in France are often
combustible volatile and violent Affairs
but this is one is different because
there's a focal point to all this anger
and that is Emmanuel macron
macron's opponents have always alleged
he is aloof and out of touch now the
criticism seems endemic even among those
who voted for him
Macon can see here and sense this Fury
but he's showing no sign of changing his
mind his hope is that all this will
dissipate but this is an angry country
reconciliation won't come easily
well the scars are still around Paris I
just looked down at my feet and found
this which is a lump of the street that
was chipped away in order to be used as
a projectile to throw at police there
was significant clashes right here on
this corner earlier I saw a man being
hit by a rock that had been thrown from
the crowd we saw police pushing
protesters uh to and fro and and
grappling with each other the simple
question now though is is how does
France move on from this because of
course as we said in our report this
wasn't isolated to Paris this was across
the country hundreds of people have been
arrested about a hundred of them here in
Paris the remainder though the majority
around the rest of France and that the
battle will continue the political
battle we see no sign I don't think of
Emmanuel macron uh backing down remember
he's in his second term as president he
doesn't face a re-election campaign so
to an extent he doesn't have to worry
about popularity contest going forward
what about the reaction of trade unions
well lots of people we spoke to said we
need to carry on with this we need to
continue with our with our protest trade
unions will in fact meet tomorrow to
discuss what their next steps will be
but there is a certain deadlock here
macron says France cannot afford to not
put up its retirement age many people in
these streets say well that is
unacceptable and that he is defined
democracy
Adam updating us there from the streets
of Paris thank you
well meanwhile thousands of nurses in
England walked out today as part of
their dispute with the government
overpay the head of the largest nurses
Union told Sky News that the disruption
could continue up until Christmas if the
government doesn't offer a better pay
deal well the offer currently on the
table then is a five percent pay
increase and lump sum offer of between 1
655 and
3789 pounds this financial year for NHS
workers in England so far the Royal
College of Nursing and unite members
have both rejected that deal however
it's being backed by some of Britain's
largest unions including Unison and the
GMB as well as the Royal College of
midwives and the chartered Society of
physiotherapy those unions represent a
majority of the workers tomorrow the
unions will meet NHS and government
representatives to discuss the offer
which could be imposed by the government
if a majority vote to accept the deal go
quick no one reports
it's May Day and workers are making
their voices heard
[Applause]
few are louder than NHS workers counting
just on my salary definitely I can't
afford the money stuff I have my
daughter and family to support so I
don't go around to pay for the holidays
three four one next is on the floor
for the first time nurses who work on
cancer Awards a d and intensive care
have joined the walkout the government
has offered them and other NHS workers a
five percent pay rise but the Royal
College of Nursing says it's not enough
we want to address Recruitment and
Retention within the NHS and
particularly within the nursing
Workforce unfortunately five percent is
not going to be able to do that
time patients are losing out unless I
have the operation it's unlikely I will
live to the end of the year
the blocked artery but her operation has
been repeatedly canceled she's among
more than half a million patients who
have seen their vital medical
appointments delayed I had a phone call
on Friday to say we're on a go for
Monday today
and
um the uh four hours later they phoned
me up and said we have to cancel Monday
because of the nurses strikes so you
know it's just a waiting game at the
moment and hoping that I stay alive for
people like sue the outcome of this
negotiation is life-changing the latest
action comes ahead of a critical meeting
between NHS buses Health unions and
ministers where the latest payoffer will
be discussed however the nurses say they
don't need to wait for the outcome of
that they already know that the offer
isn't good enough and they've rubbished
any suggestions that they're acting
prematurely
so while the Royal College of Nursing
warns defiantly that strike action could
last until Christmas
Health unions are expected to approve
the government's offer tomorrow
that means members could see a deal they
rejected imposed on them the question is
whether all the unions will tomorrow
accept this deal and we can move on but
as I say that will still leave major
issues the government needs to address
in terms of Staffing and Health Service
so for all the clamor a deal with health
workers seems closer than ever gurpreet
no one Sky News
well our chief political correspondent
John Craig joins us now from Downing
Street so what should we expect tomorrow
then John
King of the end for many of the strikes
in the National Health Service some of
which have dragged on for about six
months but the Royal College of Nursing
is going to go down fighting now tonight
Pat Cullen the General Secretary of the
RCN has issued a defiant and angry
statement saying that tomorrow's meeting
with Steve Barkley appears a foregone
conclusion now she says that different
unions and different professions came to
different and she says respectable
conclusions on this payoffer the deal
being accepted by others she says does
not alter the clear fact that nursing
staff as the largest part of the NHS
Workforce remain in dispute why with the
government over what she calls unfair
pay and unfair Staffing so tomorrow
around about lunchtime there'll be a
meeting of all the union Representatives
before they go and meet the NHS bosses
and government officials and the reason
we seem to be heading for a breakthrough
which of course the Prime Minister will
welcome as he tries to get waiting lists
down is because the numbers stack up
like this now the group that's called
agenda for change that's the
representatives of all the various
Health unions it's like an electoral
college and the RCN which is what is
going to reject the offer has nine votes
but Unison that is going to accept has
12 the GMB accepting has three midwives
three they're accepting unite four but
they're rejecting now Sky News has
calculated that it's it's about 25 for
accepting the offer uh votes and about
17 for rejecting it so the signs are
that they the there will be a vote to
accept the latest offer of course NHS
bosses have four weeks been pressed
pleading with the government to solve
these strikes because of course it's one
of the prime minister's five priorities
and the NHS bosses have been saying to
ministers and the Prime Minister how can
we get waiting lists down with these
strikes going on well tomorrow we are
likely to see a breakthrough and that
the numbers suggest that the majority of
those voting and the meeting with the
government will vote to accept the offer
that the RCN are going down fighting
defiant and angry they're saying that
their dispute with the government still
goes on even if the pay it Ray Rises are
imposed
John live there in Danny street thank
you
to Sudan now and face battles and Air
Raids are reported to be continuing in
Khartoum despite another supposed
ceasefire being in place tonight the
front office here has confirmed that 2
197 people have been moved out of the
country in what they claim is the
longest and largest evacuation from
Sudan by any Western Nation additional
flights took off earlier from Port Sudan
giving British Nationals perhaps their
last chance to leave the region where
the situation is clearly deteriorating
the United Nations Refugee agency says
around 73 000 people have already left
the country in that the agency is
planning for a total of eight hundred
and fifteen thousand to potentially
leave our correspondent Israel Berger
reports now from Port Sudan
Ash Allah it's the last leg of the
longest journey of their lives
and they anxiously wait for their names
to be called
British evacuations continue
and everyone here is a British citizen
who's leaving someone behind
evacuation flights have basically moved
from
the capital to here in Port Sudan so
everyone you see here has made a very
long journey by car over a day to get
here and get home to Britain
for those being evacuated there's a lot
of relief but the process is bittersweet
like I'm thankful I'm
thinking to go back home but
I'm not number 48 I'm Mishka doctor you
understand
I feel very selfish and privileged it's
like a mix between guilt and relief to
be on this flight to be fair
waiting at the same airport are those
Left Behind after a Turkish evacuation
plane came under Fire Landing north of
hartum this group of Turkish students
and residents were relocated to Port
Sudan airport they've been sleeping in
the mosque for the last three nights now
we contact them and they said it's a
safe place here but there is no plan
coming from Turkey
is
what do you have to say to the Turkish
government is
and this man An Egyptian in Exile has
limited options you can't go back to
Egypt or any other country in the Middle
East
foreign
another step away from and one stop away
from the UK
R Sky News Port Sudan
Investment Banking giant JP Morgan is
set to take over the troubled U.S Bank
First Republic in a deal broken by
Regulators the bank is the third major
U.S Bank to collapse in the last few
months JP Morgan has agreed a deal with
Regulators to acquire the substantial
majority of first Republic's assets
President Joe Biden has sought to assure
Americans of the steps taken by the
regulators and so the nation is well on
our way to stabilizing the banking
system these actions are going to make
sure that the banking system is safe and
sound
and that includes protecting small
businesses across the country who need
to make payroll for workers and their
small businesses and so let me be very
clear all the positors are being
protected shareholders are losing their
Investments and critically taxpayers are
not the ones that are on the hook
a woman believed to be in her 30s has
died after being stabbed in South London
the Metropolitan Police said it was
called around 4 pm reports of a stabbing
in Stockwell Park walk officers
paramedics and an air ambulance attended
the woman was pronounced dead at the
scene a number of roads are currently
closed with a cordon in place
a number of people have been killed and
dozens left injured
in car crashes along the 55 Interstate
in Illinois during a dust storm roughly
40 to 60 Passenger cars and several
trucks were involved in the crash the
Illinois State Police spokesman said 30
people have been transported to local
hospitals with injuries
one of the world's most important fossil
deposits has been found in Wales the
discovery includes fossils of many soft
bodied creatures which are extremely
rare and were found near London wells in
Paris the fossils were in rocks which
had been laid down under the sea over
460 million years ago at a time when
what is now mid Wales was underwater
well these pictures showed them imagined
as living creatures it's hoped they will
provide a new insight into how life was
evolving at that time
it's nearly a century since Donald
Trump's mother emigrated from Scotland
to the United States but the former
president declared it was great to be
home when he landed in Aberdeen today
he's visiting one of his eponymous golf
courses in a break from campaigning to
re-enter the White House and fighting
charges of falsifying business records
our Scotland correspondent connigillis
saw him arrive
whatever he goes the cameras the
controversy and the circus follows a
performance with a former president the
star of the show
Donald Trump is back in the UK for the
first time in four years
it's great to be home he said a
reference to his ancestral roots on the
same week as the Kings coronation
here in Scotland at a time when he
becomes the first U.S president in
history to be facing criminal charges it
was the moment Trump the businessman
arrived at his nearby Golf Resort time
to forget the trial he faces over
alleged hush money payments my mother
was born in Scotland she loved Scotland
was a great admirer of the queen and I
got to know the queen so well on my
trips to Scotland and to UK generally
but I got to know her she was an
incredible woman my mother loved the
queen but the warm welcome does not
extend too far this the message to a
president from some of his aberdeenshire
neighbors is he welcome here or not uh
no uh to be honest with you the first
time he came you know he just caused so
much problems he forced people out the
houses don't see the problem with Donald
Trump been here a businessman brings a
lot to the community and and you've got
the hat for it as well yes I've had this
hat for six years so I've always been a
supporter
here is Trump at his other Resort in
airshow a few years ago a Scottish
business Empire facing financial
problems the latest accounts revealing
4.4 million pound losses I think this is
part of sort of separating his political
Ambitions this is more focused on his
business Ambitions in trying to
revitalize these businesses I think
which again as I said have been
suffering a little bit over the last
couple of years it all comes down with
Donald Trump it all comes down to
perception into publicity and I think
he's hoping that this visit will give a
boost of publicity to his golf courses
I'm not sure how successful that will be
this fleeting visit to the UK may be a
moment of relief for Donald Trump and he
will hope boost his business's bottom
line there are though plenty of
questions for him back home as he
battles to get back in to the White
House Conor Gillis Sky News
aberdeenshire
now they're not the names you'd imagine
would have been invited to the last
coronation but Lionel Richie plus aunt
and deck have been confirmed as among
the congregation for King Charles's big
day some of those some of those lucky
enough to have attended 70 years ago
have been speaking to our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock
we were bought back
from
the series canal
to line the route
for the queen
[Applause]
it was the scale of the thing which made
it special
and she was radiant and she was
dedicated you could see in her face
she's gone to do something really really
serious
Millions watched the last coronation but
a few had a unique View
Anne Harris was 17 and sat in a
grandstand right outside the Abbey the
first we knew anything was about to
happen apart from the clock was the
beginning of
a rumble of noise which got louder and
louder it was like a big wave of
cheering coming up inside the Abbey was
Richard Watts a nine-year-old chorister
and after the Fanfare we started to sing
I was glad and the queen then steps
forward and
slowly goes up in procession
he knew the queen was beneath us when
the Westminster School
boys sang the vivance
and then we responded with a full quiet
and organ version vibes
after the coronation the precession and
lining the root was Victor Needham
Crofton it was a proud moment for me
yeah I always did like dress it up he
remembers the crowds and the rain poor
and rain every single minute of the day
but I didn't care
my queen was going to be on the throne
and I loved it so this is you on your
way
to Buckingham Palace yeah the Heavy Rain
almost canceled the fly past if the
cloud base was down to about a thousand
fifteen hundred feet it's too too
dangerous but as his log book shows
Terry Devi Smith did take off and so
there's a palace over there so of course
one could just look up so you had a
quick look of course of course I've been
I bet everyone then as the pilots looked
down the royal family looked up and 70
years on Charles will be back only this
time the fly pasts for him Laura bundock
Sky News
excitement is building in Liverpool and
across Europe ahead of this month's
Eurovision song contest Liverpool might
be hosting only because last year's
winners Ukraine can't but today a
festival began in the city which will
ensure that the embattled nation is not
forgotten showcasing collaborations
between UK and Ukrainian artists Skies
Fraser Ward reports
[Music]
sequins Stardust and Sandy Shore songs
it can only mean one thing eurovision's
in town and as part of the build up this
performance of memories of music from
the world's most famous song contest is
touring care homes in Liverpool does
everyone love a bit of Eurovision I
think so I certainly do and I think
bringing the party out to Residents in
Care Homes and nursing homes is really
important for those people who really
can't participate in the party that's
happening in town we just started to
bring departure to them but Pierre had
the preparations are well underway for
the first Eurovision in the UK for 25
years with the creation of a Eurovision
Village it's fantastic sick is actually
unknown I know when you think it's so
much of Liverpool has done with the
culture with the music shows off the
city for what it is you know and puts us
around the world isn't it even more so
why do you love Eurovision I think it's
really good to see all the music and
like really brilliant people singing
there's so many different people here
who are appreciating what Liverpool is
doing and you can actually feel the city
pumping Ukraine is well represented in
the city a tribute to the country which
won the contest but is unable to host it
it includes installations like the
solaveko songbirds the national bird of
Ukraine it's important for us to talk
about what's actually happening over
there but also to bring some positive
stories about Ukraine too thousands of
fans missed out on tickets for the
semi-finals and final live shows but
they'll be well served by the many
official and unofficial parties around
the city there's bars doing kind of
Ukrainian cocktails as a whole food
program in the Ukrainian food here in
the Village there'll be a whole
Ukrainian kind of Village set up over
there that will showcase the best of
everything creatively about Ukraine so
we're really determined on that but yeah
the city absolutely knows how to party
so it's no longer the time for making
your mind up about the event it's
already here and this city of music is
going to make sure it goes with a boom
Banger Bang Fraser mode Sky News
Liverpool
[Music]
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers and the
including this story on the front page
of the eye the headline this can't go on
NHS leaders in despair they say as
strike stalemates hits a care backlog
and tonight we'll be joined by the
columnist and broadcaster Steve Richards
and the former conservative special
advisor Salma Shaw
foreign
[Music]